donc quelles sont les dernières infos là
j'ai alors il y a une info un peu
connexe mais qui est très étonnante
c'est un des hommes qui avait accusé
Pierre Palmade de détenir des images
pédopornographiques vous souvenez de
l'affaire alors est-ce que vous pouvez
nous rappeler cette affaire il y a deux
mecs c'est lui qui a appelé
la brigade qui a appelé la brigade des
mineurs pour dire que Perpignan détenez
des images pornographiques c'est lui qui
sait faire cet homme là a été condamné à
deux ans de prison dont un avec sursis
pour avoir fourni et vendu de la drogue
lors de soirée comme sexe pour résumer
il aurait touché il a touché 184000
euros en deux ans et donc il vient
d'être condamné par le tribunal
correctionnel de Paris il avait fourni
des drogues de synthèse en fait dont les
drogues de synthèse dont on parle pour
les soirées cam sex a des gens qui
venaient chez lui à son domicile
parisien il payait 10 euros le droit
d'entrée et 30 euros de supplémentaires
s'ils voulaient des drogues il a fait ça
pendant plusieurs années et il vient
d'être condamné alors ça n'a pas
d'influence directe mais quelqu'un qui
accuse Pierre Palmade de détenir des
images et qui très peu de temps après
condamné
on va dire que ça affaiblit un tout
petit peu la véracité potentielle de son
témoignage voilà et puis revaloise il
est toujours sous contrôle judiciaire
toujours hospitalisé et l'instruction se
poursuit et pour le moment il y a des
actes d'instruction mais que l'on ne
connaît pas voilà et pour les trois
victimes toujours le conducteur le plus
gravement touché qui est encore
hospitalisé encore hospitalier
hospitalisé d'accord et donc ils
attendent que Pierre Palma aille mieux
pour est-ce qu'on a dit une nouvelle de
il y aura de l'État turple ce qu'on
entend tout et son contraire il y en a
qui disent que c'est vraiment un AVC
très grave il y en a qui disent que
c'est moins grave moi on m'a dit voilà
qu'apparemment c'était plutôt
sérieux et que voilà et que c'était pas
c'était pas un petit AVC donc c'est vrai
que vous avez les mêmes infos que moi
mais oui parce que ce qui est totalement
vos infos sont totalement confirmés par
la décision de dire que vu son état
il serait exceptionnel qu'il puisse
réitérer le fait de prendre une voiture
et de conduire c'est ça qui avait motivé
la décision il aurait pu être incarcéré
mais le juge avait dit vu son état il me
semble quasi impossible qui est
réitération de l'acte donc ça corrobore
vos informations entre guillemets le la
Chambre d'appel avait jugé qu'il n'était
pas en état potentiellement de s'enfuir
de conduire etc ça veut dire que son
état de santé j'ai sérieux par les
experts médicaux et donc par la chambre
de l'instruction donc oui c'est pas un
petit AVC Bénin dont on se remet en
trois jours vous avez des infos vous
Jean-Marie ou pas du tout
non non je me dis moi avec mon coeur que
c'est AVC c'est ça doit être une espèce
de de suicide intellectuel tu vois c'est
à dire un moment où tu peux plus
supporter ce que tu es ou ce que tu as
fait un truc comme ça et peut-être que
tu te tu te tords un boyau de la tête et
c'est sûrement ce qui s'est passé dans
la tête c'est tellement il a tellement
tu te rends compte
tous les matins en disant voilà je
serais responsable de ça c'est
terrifiant je souhaite à personne
c'est que les journalistes on aime ou on
n'aime pas mais qui ont accès à tous les
rapports de police contacés à la justice
contacter à tous les horaires les
machins et tout n'est pas accès aux
rapports de cet AVC qui de surcroît a eu
lieu dans un hôpital et on sait très
bien que dans les hôpitaux quant à
lagerfeldor c'est un c'est un
brancardier qui a appelé directement les
paparazzi et je rappelle qu'il a dit
Karl lagafal est mort Dior a d'abord
démenti et ensuite a dit il est mort
c'est-à-dire que les papa dis le savait
avant donc on sait que dans les hôpitaux
comme dans la police il y a des fuites
que personne ne se rapporte des WC alors
qu'il a eu lieu et que personne ne sache
si effectivement un AVC parfois si c'est
pris très tôt ou pas ça change est-ce
qu'il peut parler est-ce qu'il peut
bouger c'est pas du tout c'est pas tu
vois c'est très étonnant il y a un truc
qui est un petit peu lourd genre cette
histoire c'est que normalement c'est
impossible qui est pas pardon de le dire
mais on le sait un brancardi un mec dans
un hôpital qui est fourni déjà le
rapport et que a pas paradis soit pas au
courant exactement de ce qu'il y a dans
cet AVC c'est
encore plus de sécurité au niveau autour
de lui c'est impossible de Jordan de
luxe quand même arrivé à pénétrer dans
l'hôpital avec ces métros
mais autant les actes judiciaires toutes
les procédures les interrogatoires etc
ça honnêtement ça fuite on devrait pas
le dire parce que maintenant il y a une
instruction bancaire mais ça fuite en
revanche le secret médical en France
globalement tant qu'il n'y a pas une
personne décédée et donc après on a le
rapport final tout ce qui est maladie
accident Jean-Luc Delarue de la rue le
dossier les futé
quand même donc les journalistes
cherchent mais vous avez raison sans
doute par incompétence n'ont-ils pas
encore détectés
le dossier le dossier médical des des
victimes on sait tout avec les fractures
les dossiers la mâchoire parce que la
famille oui d'accord mais donc ça veut
dire que malgré tout on a aussi accès au
dossier médicaux
si particulière titulaire enfin
l'avocate de Pierre Palmade ne parle pas
elle ne parle pas quand il y a les
appels à la chambre d'instruction elle
sort sans dire un mot elle ne commente
aucune décision donc elle protège
totalement tout ce qui concerne son
client
voilà pour que des paparazzi Sébastien
valliella et tout ça même quand il avait
sous-marin qui était venu à Paris des
fuites dans les hôpitaux c'est c'est les
puces d'eau quoi
c'est c'est très étonnant que personne
ne puisse dire aujourd'hui est-ce que
peut-être que c'est parce qu'on a peur
de communiquer sur le fait que c'est un
AVC peut-être pas très grave et qu'on se
dit que si on dit aux gens que c'est il
va très bien qui parle qui bouge qui
regarde la télé les gens sont un panique
je sais pas ce qui se passe mais je dis
juste que il est passé d'un hôpital à
l'autre quand il a fait la vaisselle il
avait laissé lui dans l'hôpital je sais
pas combien de personnes dans les
hôpitaux les brancardiers les
réceptionnistes les machins et je tape
sur personne mais la police et tout mais
quand vous quand vous savez comment les
paparazzis sont équipés aujourd'hui pour
avoir tous les rapports quand le
Schumacher est arrivé dans un hôpital il
y avait 10 gardes du corps les les
paparazzis ont réussi à faire une photo
et à s'emparer de les mecs sont hyper
doués et là juste sur ce cas là ils ont
pas de rapport parce qu'il y a un juge
d'instruction qui noyau et cloisonne
tout le truc instructions
[Musique]
je m'étonne je pars pas sur ne faites
pas partir sur un truc complotiste je
dis juste que je suis étonné parce que
c'est vrai que c'est la question qu'on
aimerait savoir aujourd'hui et
franchement je souhaite que ce qu'il
aille bien je vous souhaite de mal à
personne mais c'est vrai que c'est pas
la même chose si il est il y en avait ça
dans ma famille ici effectivement il
aime paralysie si il peut plus parler
s'il aphasie et si au contraire il a
fait cette non mais vous hé on a des
infos dites la vérité quoi honnêtement
serrer le sur l'examen médical lié à
l'AVC on a des infos qui fuitent mais on
n'a pas le compte-rendu on n'a pas à
moins que vous voulez lui vous mais moi
sais pas le compte rendu de l'AVC la
gravité exacte c'est quand même très
tenu secret par son avocat et quand
l'avocat ne parle pas s'il parle ou pas
dure cette rupture il a le droit de
marcher dans l’hôpital après que
quelqu'un dise il a pu marcher dans
l'hôpital mais moi j'attends ça l'ai vu
voilà exactement personne n'a dit il a
pu marcher dans l'hôpital et personne ne
l'a vu mais ça c'est vrai on reconnaît
que là on a peut-être une faille d'infos
vous avez raison c'est pas mal non mais
c'est mais c'est la bonne question je
suis d'accord